OK, I filled your brain with a
bunch of partial derivatives
and psi's, with respect
to x's and y's.
I think now it's time to
actually do it with a real
differential equation,
and make things a
little bit more concrete.
So let's say I have the
differential, y, the
differential equation, y cosine
of x, plus 2xe to the
y, plus sine of x, plus-- I'm
already running out of space--
x squared, e to the y,
minus 1, times y
prime, is equal to 0.
Well, your brain is already,
hopefully, in exact
differential equations mode.
But if you were to see this
pattern in general, where you
see a function of x and y,
here-- this is just some
function of x and y-- and then
you have another function of x
and y, times y prime, or times
dy, d of x, your brain should
immediately say if this
is inseparable.
And I'm not going to try to
make it separable, just
because that'll take
a lot of time.
But if it's not separable, your
brain said, oh, maybe
this is an exact equation.
And, you say, let
me test whether
this is an exact equation.
So if this is an exact equation,
this is our function
M, which is a function
of x and y.
And this is our function
N, which is a
function of x and y.
Now, the test is to see if the
partial of this, with respect
to y, is equal to the partial
of this, with respect to x.
So let's see.
The partial of M, with respect
to y, is equal to-- let's see,
y is-- so this cosine of x is
just a constant, so it's just
cosine of x.
Cosine of x plus-- now,
what's the derivative?
Well, 2x is just a constant,
what's the derivative of e to
the y, with respect to y?
Well, it's just e
to the y, right?
So we have the constant on
the outside, 2x times the
derivative, with respect to
y, so it's 2xe to the y.
Fair enough.
Now, what is the partial
derivative of this, with
respect to x?
So N sub x, or the partial of
N, with respect to x-- so
what's the derivative of sine
of x, with respect to x?
Well, that's easy, that's cosine
of x, plus 2x times e
to the y, right? e and y is just
a constant, because y is
constant when we're taking the
partial, with respect to x.
So plus 2xe to the y.
And then minus 1, the derivative
of a constant, with
respect to anything
is going to be 0.
So the derivative of N-- the
partial of N, with respect to
x, is cosine of x, plus 2xe to
the y, which, lo and behold,
is the same thing as the
derivative, the partial of M,
with respect to y.
So there we have it.
We've shown that M of y is equal
to-- or the partial of
M, with respect to y-- is equal
to the partial of N,
with respect to x, which
tells us that
this is an exact equation.
Now, given that this is an exact
equation-- oh, my wife
snuck up behind me,
I was wondering.
I thought there was
some critter in
my house, or something.
Anyway, so we know that this is
an exact equation, so what
does that tell us?
Well, that tells us that there's
some psi, where the
partial derivative of psi, with
respect to x, is equal to
M, and the partial derivative of
psi, with respect to y, is
equal to N.
And if we know that psi,
then we can rewrite our
differential equation as the
derivative of psi, with
respect to x, is equal to 0.
So let's solve for psi.
So we know that the partial of
psi, with respect to x, is
equal to M.
So we could write that.
We could write the partial of
psi, with respect to x, is
equal to M, which is y cosine
of x, plus 2xe to the y.
That's just here.
That's my M of x.
We could have done
it the other way.
We could have said the partial
of y-- the partial of psi,
with respect to y, is this
thing over here.
But let's just do it with x.
Now, to at least get kind of a
first approximation of what
size-- not an approximation, but
to start to get a sense of
it-- let's take the derivative
of both sides, with respect
to-- sorry, take the
antiderivative-- take the
integral of both sides,
with respect to x.
So if you take the derivative of
this, with respect to x, if
you integrate-- sorry, if
you were to take the
antiderivative of this,
with respect to x.
So let me just write
that down.
The partial, with
respect to x.
We're going to [? integrate ?]
it, with respect to x.
That is going to be equal to
the integral of this whole
thing, with respect to x.
Cosine of x plus 2xe to the y.
We're integrating with
respect to x.
And normally when you integrate
with respect to x,
you'd say, OK, plus c, right?
But it actually could be a
plus-- since this is a
partial, with respect to x, we
could have had some function
of y here in general, because
y, we treat it
as a constant, right?
And that makes sense, because
if you were to take the
partial of both sides of this,
with respect to x, if you were
to take the partial of a
function that is only a
function of y, with respect
to x, you would
have gotten a 0 here.
So when you take the
antiderivative, you were,
like, oh well, there might have
been some function of y
here that we lost when
we took the partial,
with respect to x.
So anyway, this will
simplify to psi.
psi is going to be equal to the
integral, with respect to
x, or the antiderivative, with
respect to x, here, plus some
function of y that we might
have lost when we took the
partial, with respect to x.
So let's do that.
Let's figure out
this integral.
I'll do it in blue So y
is just a constant.
So the antiderivative of y
cosine of x, is just y sine of
x, plus-- either the y
is constant, so 2x.
The antiderivative of 2x, with
respect to x, is x squared, so
it's x squared e to the y.
And then plus some
function of y.
And if you want to verify this,
you should take the
partial of this, with
respect to x.
If you take the partial of
this, with respect to x,
you're going to get this in
here, which is our function,
M, up here.
And then when you take the
partial of this, with respect
to x, you'll get 0, and
it'll get lost. OK, so
we're almost there.
We've almost figured out our
psi, but we still need to
figure out this function of y.
Well, we know that if we take
the partial of this, with
respect to y, since this
is an exact equation,
we should get this.
We should get our N function.
So let's do that.
So the partial-- I'll switch
notation, just to expose you
to it-- the partial psi, with
respect to y, is going to be
equal to-- so here, y sine
of x, sine of x is just a
constant. y is just y, so the
derivative of this, with
respect to y, is
just sine of x.
Plus the derivative of e to the
y is e to the y. x squared
is just a constant.
So it's just x squared e to
the y, plus-- what's the
partial of f of y, with
respect to y?
It's going to be f prime of y.
Well, what did we do?
We took M, we integrated with
respect to x, and we said,
well, we might have lost some
function of y, so we added
that to it.
And then we took the partial of
that side that we've almost
constructed, and we took
the partial of that,
with respect to y.
Now, we know, since this is
exact, that that is going to
equal our N.
So our N is up there.
Cosine of x plus-- So that's
going to be equal to-- I want
to make sure I can read it up
there-- to our N, right?
Oh no, sorry.
N is up here.
Our N is up here.
Sine of x-- let me write
that-- sine of x plus x
squared, e to the y, minus 1.
So sine of x plus x squared,
e to the y, minus 1.
That was just our N,
from our original
differential equation.
And now we can solve
for f prime of y.
So let's see, we get sine of x
plus x squared, e to the y,
plus f prime of y, is equal to
sine of x plus x squared, e to
the y, minus 1.
So let's see, we can delete
sine of x from both sides.
We can delete x squared e to
the y from both sides.
And then what are
we left with?
We're left with f prime
of y is equal to 1.
And then we're left with f of
y is equal to-- well, it
equals y plus some constant,
c, right?
So what is our psi now?
We wrote our psi up here, and we
had this f of y here, so we
can rewrite it now.
So psi is a function of x and
y-- we're actually pretty much
almost done solving it-- psi
is a function of x and y is
equal to y sine of x, plus x
squared, e to the y, plus y--
oh, sorry, this is f prime
of y, minus 1.
So this is a minus 1.
So this is a minus y plus c.
So this is going to be
a minus y plus c.
So we've solved for psi.
And so what does that tell us?
Well, we said that original
differential equation, up
here, using the partial
derivative chain rule, that
original differential equation,
can be rewritten now
as the derivative dx of psi is
equal to-- psi is a function
of x and y-- is equal to 0.
Or if you were to integrate both
sides of this, you would
get that psi of xy is equal
to c is a solution of that
differential equation.
So if we were to set this is
equal to c, that's the
differential equation.
So we could say, y sine of x
plus x squared, e to the y,
minus y-- now we could say, plus
this c-- plus this c, you
call it c1, is equal to c2.
Well, you could subtract the c's
from both sides, and just
be left with a c at the end.
But anyway, we have solved
this exact equation, one,
first, by recognizing it was
exact, by taking the partial
of this, with respect to y, and
seeing if that was equal
to the partial of N,
with respect to x.
Once we saw that they were
equal, we're like, OK, this is
going to be exact.
So let's figure out psi.
Since this is exact, M is going
to be the partial of
psi, with respect to x.
N is the partial of psi,
with respect to y.
Then to figure out y, we
integrated M, with respect to
x, and we got this.
But since we said, oh, well,
instead of a plus c, it could
have been a function of y there,
because we took the
partial, with respect to x, so
this might have been lost. To
figure out the function of y,
we then took our psi that we
figured out, took the partial
of that, with
respect to y, got this.
And we said, this was an exact
equation, so this is going to
equal our N of x y.
We set those equal to each
other, and then we
solved for f of y.
And then we had our final psi.
Our final psi was this.
And then the differential
equation, because of the chain
rule of partial derivatives,
we could rewrite the
differential equation as this.
The solution is this, and so
this is the solution to our
differential equation.
See you in the next video.